we have this beautiful new set and we
have what do you think you like it I
really do like it yeah it's a little
smaller it's a little more intimate it's
got some different colors that's right
and one thing that's a little different
at the top of the show I used to come
out that way
and now I come out through this door
right here you know that's how I came
out tonight yeah then I took that oh
yeah
just to look back it's flat back
flashback Monday to 8 seconds ago yeah
when I came out and that door did you go
uh yeah he was looking for me over there
it still feels weird it's weird because
I've come one way for a long time I'm
not convinced it's the best entrance on
the new set you know and so what I
thought is let's try out a couple right
here see how they feel you let me know
which one you like for example because I
know you're all of you are very
reluctant to let me know how you feel
anyway for example I could come out from
the side where I used to enter but
instead I could change it up just a
little bit so it looks a little
different but still come from the same
side try that right now yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
no string dance what the hell was that
get that for big Paul or stagehand okay
it's alright
okay you know we could do better than
that let me try this and let me know
what you think of this we could try me
entering through the audience people I'm
gonna spice it up dressed as a Catholic
archbishop what do you think of that
[Applause]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
I gotta say this one is very hard to be
I'm I bet this is your mom's favorite
this is gonna my mom's watching right
now crying I think we could try one more
that might be just a little bit have a
little more pizzazz let's try that just
right now Jimmy could you hit it
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
keep working on I promise to keep
working on it how about that
you